let's take a different approach from
something that you know you're you're
more into sort of the story formation
and producing the show but what if
someone comes to LA and wants to be a
reality star okay what what do they have
to have mm-hmm what do they need to do
what kind of things well it's not too
hard to get on a reality show if you
live in Los Angeles because they're
casting around the clock they'll post
often on Craigslist people will actually
recruit for reality shows you'll see
people just approaching people in public
places and saying hey have you ever
thought about blah blah blah what you
need to know going into it is if you're
on tape or you're asked to submit
something be yourself don't be a cartoon
version of yourself to be interesting
I have almost never seen that work there
are times where it has worked but it's
been very rare the real you is who they
want to see and they may ask you for a
heightened version of yourself or if I
talk non-stop about a particular subject
they'll say okay when you get on the
show just talk about it a lot another
thing you should really know getting
into reality shows is that reality stars
do not make a tremendous amount of money
when you start a reality show there are
a lot of people that will be paid
stipends of maybe 500 bucks a week to be
on a show there are major celebrities
that I have seen on shows who might get
$3,000 in episode that it's something
that's done in addition to their normal
life trying to make a living as a
reality star is pretty tough now when
you get into the second or third or
fourth or fifth season of a show there's
a little bit more money there and you
have some leverage and you can say well
you know the few years that I got on the
show are up net or the few years of my
initial contract are up now let's
renegotiate and that's where you start
to hear about things like the duck
dynasty guys want more money or the
Housewives of Blanc want you know more
money that people are starting to push
for that what you need to know is a
reality star is that
there is a brief window of time where
you are going to be exposed to a lot of
people it is not a career don't chase it
because you're gonna last five to seven
eight seasons on the show that's really
hot and then you're gonna disappear
there's gonna be nothing so it's all
about trying to figure out how to
capitalize on the experience of having
been on a show you look at people like
Bethenny Frankel and what she was able
to do as a result of having camera time
and being out there she was really
hustling and pushing her own product and
doing her thing and was able to build an
empire most people in reality shows
don't do that I will tell you that there
are there's an agent with a major agency
that I had spoken to once about reality
shows as far as the representation for
reality stars his take was you know
every year a show like Big Brother will
come out and there will be a huge cast
of people that all decide that they want
to be represented when the show ends it
was like well what do you do well I'm
the chick with the blue hair what do you
do well I'm gonna kick with the blue
hair on Big Brother and and you know I'm
kind of famous because I'm on Big
Brother there's nowhere for them to take
you there's nothing for them to do with
you managers and publicists are the
people who will be handling you trying
to figure out how to help you capitalize
on your fame but it's up to you to
figure out what to make of the time you
have on the show in order to make it
count or just realize that it's
something that you do for the fun of
being involved in it
there aren't there are no we shouldn't
say no there are very few lasting stars
coming out of reality nene leakes is the
exception not it not be not the rule any
advice for people post reality stardom
how do they assimilate back into quote
normal life or maybe that's one of the
things they have to realize is that it's
always going to follow them I think that
if you have some level of notoriety for
being
of pain or being somebody who's kind of
like the character that's always sort of
jabbing at people if that's what you
have a reputation for that's very hard
to shake and it can follow you into a
job it can follow you into your life
where people just perceive you as the
person that you've been on the show I
know some people personally that that
has happened too but most people who are
on reality shows unless there's a super
negative thing surrounding you can
assimilate back into normal life fairly
easily you might get a Hello at the
grocery store hey weren't you on
so-and-so but there's so much content
out that people don't really it's not
something that lasts a long time and you
just have to have a mindset going into
it that this is something that I want to
do because it'll be fun it'll be an
adventure for me but it's not a career
move it's like a 1% it's not a career
move if you have a if you have a very
specific agenda if you're going on a
show like Project Runway or you're gonna
do a show where it's about your talent
or your skill or your ability and your
talent or skill or ability is showcased
on that show that's slightly different
you'll be you know you may be approached
by people after that there are crazy
opportunities they're afforded to you
while you were on the shows that just
don't tend to last you know you get paid
to open a nightclub just show up and
wave at people and say hello and let's
get this party started and then you're
in a car and you're gone
there are crazy things that can happen
to you while you're on the show but it's
not something that's designed to last
you